i am curious what is the status of
sleeping dogs because you've talked
about that before you know based on the
video game do you think that's going to
happen
i'm still hopeful i mean
every day they tell me it's going to
happen
i'm telling i've been hearing from
my my i'm co-producing and collaborating
with neil mares and toby
with uh
with their company and
currently with talking with a couple of
big platforms so
and they tell me every single day it's
gonna happen so we'll see like i said i
believe in destiny
if it's going to happen
hopefully happen the first
half of next year
can i ask you what is it about that
property um that says i want to make
this is it have you played the game do
you have you read a script that you
really like honestly it was like this
i did a
very i did a film
that uh not very proud of
we all made some shitty films right i
made a film called uh
the iceman
uh
a few years ago right one of the
producers came to me and said oh you
know donnie i saw this game this game is
perfect
sony game
and he showed me that
the cover and the guy actually looked a
little
like what i did in my other films right
and i looked at some of the clips the
way they fight and some of them move my
moves
and
and then i did some research and i found
some articles saying that the person
there's a group of people who created
this game created the world they want
their fans on mine and they
pretty much borrow some my actions and
even the image you know kind of and i
said oh this that could be a fun vehicle
because
like i said i was caught in the 12 13
years of the eight man image that i want
to go back to
action contemporary action
and when i look at this material i said
wow
this could be a perfect action
like
contemporary action
world that i can i could do and it's
it's already have a fan base right it it
it's
uh internal internal affair and uh
uh you know flashpoint uh you know it
got all those elements kind of like
region five but even more edgier because
i'm playing undercover so i could do
so many things right it was very
uh at the time it was very uh
you know i was
really uh
attracted to it
and then the device went back and forth
from back and forth and i tried to
inquire to sony's and and it costed too
much and they wanted too much money and
it went back and forth back for years
right
and then uh
i got a call from uh numerous two years
ago they said they got the properties
then we started talking and it's been a
few years we've been talking and talking
and talking and talking you know how
slow it is in hong kong we make like
five movies already right and we're
still in discussion you know i do own
the rights of the filmmaking so i want
to let you know that right i own the
right
you know and i have full intention and
still wanted to do it and but how the
story is going to go is it going to it's
it's going to based on the the game or
uh
maybe some elements is
tracks
attracts uh from the the
from the games but most likely you're
probably gonna
make
a more of a modern like a updated
version of sleeping dogs but i'm still
in every bit of in
ambitions to to honor to make that
because
i invested many years of
uh
kind of uh
into into this these projects and
now i'm not backing out now and they and
they and they promised me they tell me
every day it's gonna happen so
hopefully it will happen so because i
don't wanna promise the fans and they
it's not gonna happen but it looks like
it's gonna happen is wait did you say
that you own the rights or neil morris
owns the rights
the movie making right uh the making
that right
this this i owns this
okay got it i understand well the other
thing about the property is that and and
maybe you agree with me and maybe you
don't i've always repeatedly said you
need a cool title and if sometimes these
movies come out and they have a terrible
title and it just immediately for me i'm
like you could have done better sleeping
dogs is a good title
yeah sleeping that was good oh by the
way i think i own the uh i i'm sorry i
want to address that you know i think i
only uh
the movie making
because there's a couple ownerships i
own the the title as well
oh so
yeah
you've gone full force you're really
you're serious you you want to make well
you know i mean
uh
yeah
we're gonna do it all the way we're
gonna do it all the way you know have
you had any conversations with the game
company about possibly if this thing
gets off the ground you know making a
game based on the movie using the title
so like sleeping dogs colon
whatever it may be
i have a lot of different conversations
with
so many
so many people involved to a point where
let me just get this movie going first
because it's like
you know
uh
i don't want to lose my fire this raging
fire as well i still have a bit you know
we still have with sleeping dogs now i
think
i can i can really uh
i think it's going to be a really uh uh
fun
i can
vision
visualize the
the
the whole look of this film is going to
be a this could be something
very special but let me just focus on
getting this film made first